foreign
[Music]
this is your Tech news briefing for
Wednesday November 2nd I'm Julie Chang
for the Wall Street Journal filling in
for Zoe Thomas
a lot of us have well streaming service
fatigue subscription after a
subscription Netflix Hulu Disney plus
the list goes on
YouTube thinks it can tackle that
fatigue by selling some of those
subscriptions itself the new feature
called Prime Time channels launched this
week and it lets users buy over 30
channels like Paramount plus and
Showtime directly on YouTube the
backdrop to all of this is that YouTube
last week reported its first drop in
advertising Revenue since it started
breaking out the unit's performance
parent company Google is dealing with
its own challenges reporting its fifth
consecutive quarter of slowing sales
growth so how might this feature help
the video platform Giant and how might
this impact streaming service providers
here to answer those questions and more
is wsj reporter miles Krupa miles thank
you for coming on the show thanks for
having me so Miles YouTube ruled out an
early version of its new streaming
service store can you tell us more about
it what does it look like
sure so the idea is that these different
streaming services including Paramount
plus Showtime Stars they will all sort
of have their own page kind of like a
YouTube Creator would and the idea
really is to have these streaming
providers have their content seamlessly
slot in between the user generated
content that people know and love from
YouTube so you know one example they
keep repeating is perhaps you're
watching a trailer for a hit show on
Showtime and then because of the way
these Services work together in
YouTube's recommendation algorithms
ideally the service will then point you
to a way to subscribe to Showtime
directly through YouTube and why did
YouTube launch this new Marketplace
yeah so YouTube's big ambition which
it's largely fulfilled already is to
basically be a One-Stop shop if you want
to watch a video of any kind on any
screen so YouTube already had something
called YouTube TV which is like a Cable
Bundle it's almost 65 a month and then
of course it has things like short form
video the long form content what this is
is kind of like an in-between it's more
what they call an A La Carte option so
for people who might not want to Shell
out 65 a month for YouTube TV they can
pick and choose a few different Services
here and there and it's another way for
YouTube to capture the push towards
online streaming but at a lower dollar
cost for the consumer so ultimately
YouTube will split the subscription and
advertising revenue from these streaming
service is with the partners themselves
YouTube wouldn't tell me exactly how
that split will break down but fair to
say YouTube could be capturing probably
at least a quarter of the revenue from
these subscribers okay so that's what
YouTube gets out of it but what about
other streaming companies or
entertainment companies what would they
get out of this agreement
yeah with the broader push towards
online streaming there are a lot of
older entertainment companies that are
trying to catch up to the Netflix's and
Hulu's of the world who are kind of
coming to this a little bit late and
don't quite have the same brand name
recognition or distribution and this is
really an easy way for them to get in
front of eyeballs YouTube has more than
2 billion logged in users and if you can
get one of them to click on a Paramount
Plus subscription after watching
something related on YouTube even if
you're giving up a good amount of that
subscription Revenue that's a win if
you're sort of a second or third tier
subscription streaming service provider
couldn't other streaming services like
Netflix just offer up something similar
so Amazon and apple and Roku are
probably the best comparisons Amazon
allows you to add on individual channels
to your Prime subscription Apple TV plus
offers a sort of similar store Front for
different streaming services so it is a
crowded space YouTube so far hasn't
signed any really exclusive streaming
providers to come onto the service which
could be a difficulty but what
executives are really banking on is the
reach of YouTube
immediately allowing this to become a
big business for them what does this
move by YouTube tell us about where the
streaming industry is headed yeah the
streaming industry is in a bit of a
transformation period right now people
seem more confused than ever they might
be subscribed to different services on
different platforms and not truly
understand how much they're paying for
all the different streaming services so
I think you're seeing a few things
you're seeing some people try to offer
bundles like what Disney is doing with
Disney Plus Hulu and ESPN plus and then
you're also now seeing platforms like
YouTube saying we want to give consumers
more Choice while also trying to have
consumers be captive to YouTube's
platform right maybe it's more choice
but also we would love for you to
subscribe to all of your services
through YouTube so
they're sort of a few different ways
this shakes out and I think YouTube is
basically betting that there's a class
of consumers that wants
these Individual Services at a lower
cost and they want them all in one place
if you win it all you can get YouTube TV
for 65 a month but if you want something
that's a bit lower commitment all in one
place then you have Prime Time channels
all right miles we're gonna have to
leave it there miles Krupa reporter with
the Wall Street Journal thank you so
much for being here today thank you and
that's it for today's Tech news briefing
for more Tech stories check out our
website wsj.com I'm Julie Chang for the
Wall Street Journal thanks for listening
[Music]
foreign